Hello, everyone.
Welcome to my
lecture, Reticular
Formation.
In this lecture, we're
going to describe
the anatomical organization
and subdivisions
of the reticular
formation, especially
understand the
major functions as
well as the neurochemistry
of this area.
We're also going
to touch on the
neurophysiology of
sleep and touch on
the clinical
implications of the
dysfunction at
reticular formation.
Please note
that reticular
formation nowadays,
because of the
unclear definition,
a lot of the
textbooks doesn't
have a special
chapter for it.
You can review
the detailed
objectives in our CPG.
And I also prepared a
10-page lecture note
in the CPG at the
very end to help you
understand the content.
There isn't any
scholar or experts
here available mapping
on the complex
blueprint there isn't
very specific reticular
formation like a
direct correlation
but you can see here
the sleep disturbances
including the
cognitive impairments
are emphasized here
in great details in
our blueprint for
the usmle blueprint
there are emphasis
about reticular
formation in the normal
processes as well
as the global
cerebral dysfunction
like altered states
of consciousness,
sleep disorders, so
quite similar to our
complex blueprint.
So what is
reticular formation?
So this structure
is actually a
very blurry one,
unlike others,
has clear anatomical
boundaries.
This structure is
really, it's a long
structure, but does not
have clear boundaries
or clear anatomical
isolations of nuclei.
Initially, this was
found in a cat. So when
you make a transection
at midbrain level,
you're going to see
the cat are constantly
remaining sleeping.
And then if you make
a cut at the pond's
level, then this cat
is constantly awake,
so cannot go to sleep.
But if you make a cut
in the medulla, then
this cat has a normal
sleep-wake cycle.
So obviously, this
entire brainstem
has a very important
role in terms
of regulating the
sleep-awake cycle.
But what exactly
the locations,
you know, the
important nuclei
are not really
identifiable.
So with these, you
know, something like
these areas that does
not have the clear
nuclei at the midbrain,
pounds, or medulla,
you can see these
are blurry areas.
Those are later defined
as reticular formation.
So nowadays, we call
it extended rashly
to the lateral
hypothalamus and
caudally connecting
with the spinal cord.
So basically the
entire brainstem.
And then it does
not include the lung
projection neurons
that we talked about
previously, you know,
the lung tracks or
ascending and descending
tracks. It does not
consist of cranial
nerve nuclei that you're
going to cover with
Dr. Kurz's lecture.
What it does contain is
a lot of interneurons
in the brainstem
that can form the
reflexes. It does
still have projection
neurons that initiate
it in the brainstem. It
can go either ascending
to regulate cortex
level of a function,
or it can go
descending to regulate
spinal cord functions.
But SARS originated
from the brainstem
area, so brainstem
reticular formation. We're
going to talk about
ascending and descending
functions of those
in the next slide.
The projection
neurons release a lot
of neurotransmitters.
So those
brainstem projection
neurons has all
these famous
neurotransmitters like
serotonin,
norepinephrine, dopamine,
acetylcholine, and
histamine. So in
this lecture, you
need to pay attention
to all of these
neurotransmitters. What
is the cell bodies
producing these
transmitters and where
does those transmitter
projecting to, and
what's the main
function of these
neurotransmitters.
The first one,
serotonergic system.
As you can see here, we
have a large population
of neurons here in
the brainstem and
runs along from the
midbrain all the way to
medulla. It's called
roughy nuclei. The
roughy nuclei along
the entire brainstem
controlling the, contributing
to the arousal and
attention. This system,
you can see that
it projects all over
the brain, you know,
projects all the way to
the entire cortex and
even to the cerebellum
as well as down to
the spinal cord. So
this is a huge nuclei
called raffin nuclei.
It's the most important
serotonergic neuron
system in the brain.
So you can see it
also has a very strong
relationship modulating
pain. So the descending
modulation of the pain
sending the signals
to the spinal cord
releasing serotonin there
to regulate painful
sensation. And so for
the reticular formation,
the most important
function, remember we
talked about in the
CAT study, is to
produce activation of
the reticular
activating system to the
entire cortex. So you
can see here, you know,
the entire cortex is
receiving serotonin
projection to help
promote arousal, so
help promote an
individual to stay awake.
And for the
neurogenertic system, the
biggest and most famous
cell body located
in the locus ceruleus,
so you need to
remember that as well.
Locus ceruleus is
located in the midbrain
tegmental area.
If you recall in the
neuroanatomy lab we
talked about the
tegmental area in the
midbrain which is
anterior or ventral to the
cerebral aqueduct.
So we have the tectum
which is the
superior and inferior
colliculi and we also
have tegmentum. So
locus cellulis is
located in the midbrain
tegmental area. It
also controlling the,
contributing to the
arousal and this
RAS system, reticular
activating system.
It has important
function in terms of
regulating sleep
as well as pain. So
very similar to
serotonin previously,
right, when we
talked about arousal,
pain, and sleep-wake
cycle. In addition,
it also has autonomic
functions too.
Norepinephrine
is the most
important
neurotransmitter in the
sympathetic
nervous system.
The autonomic
functions that are
regulated by the
norepinephrine secretion.
This is a very
important system for
ascending to send
to the cortex for
arousal attention,
and then descending
regulating pain and
autonomic functions.
Another important
neurotransmitter that
originates from the
brainstem is dopamine.
And so in other
lectures, you probably
have talked about the
dopaminergic neurons,
especially later on
in the Dr. Curse's
lecture related to the
Parkinson's disease.
And but that's
actually only part
of the story. So
dopamine pathways,
including four
major pathways here.
So there is a very
important one originating
from ventral
tegmental area or VTA.
So remember, we just
talked about the
tegmentum that's in
the midbrain, right?
ventral to the aqueduct.
So ventral tegmental
area is also a small
area that does not
have clear anatomical
boundaries, but it's
very important where
the dopaminergic
neuron cell body
located. So from VTA, it
can send the axons
to the limbic area or
cortical area. So
from the VTA, it goes
either to the cortical
area called the
mesocortical pathway
or goes to the limbic
structures like nucleus
accumbens, striatum.
So for the
mesolimbic pathways,
it's related more
to addiction,
the euphoria sensation,
and also related to
the hallucinations when
there's a schizophrenic
patient experience.
The mesocortical
pathway is very
important for the
cognitive functions.
So clearly, it's
related with the
negative symptoms
of schizophrenia,
such as lack of apathy,
reduced cognition
function.
And it also has a
close relationship
with Parkinson's disease,
hypokinesia. So,
mesocortical pathway
is very important
for cognition.
And for the movement
regulation in the
Parkinson's disease, the
nigrostriato system is
the most important
dopaminergic pathway. So,
this pathway does not
start from the VTA.
It actually starts
from Substantial *****
pars compacta. So this
is the area that is
extremely important
and suffering from
degeneration in the
Parkinson's disease patients.
This is a major pathway
for coordinating
movement.
And lastly, there is a
pathway called tubular
infundibular system
that is originating
from the hypothalamus.
These dopaminergic
neurons have a relatively
simple function.
they inhibit the
prolactin release from
the pituitary gland.
So this is relatively
less important
comparing to the other
three in terms of
regulating our daily life.
So dopamine doesn't
have a whole lot of
relationship with the
sleep-weight cycle
regulation. What about
the acetylcholine?
Previously, we mentioned
about acetylcholine
that's being released
by the autonomic
nervous system and
also the lower motor
neurons use it to
innervate the muscles.
So here inside
the brainstem,
there is a large
cholinergic nuclei
called the nucleus
bacillus or
a nucleus bacillus
of Maynard.
So this is at the base of
forebrain that
project to the entire
cortex. So it's
right here.
There's another
location at the
tegmentum.
It's called the
pedunculopontine
tegmental nuclei.
That is projecting
to the brainstem
as well as to
the spinal cord.
And acetylcholine
has a very
important relationship
with cognition.
So as you know, that
Alzheimer's disease
actually is highly
involved with the decreased
of acetylcholine release
to the entire cortex.
And then you have the
cognitive deficit.
It also highly related to
the arousal
and attention.
So this is similar
to the serotonin
and norepinephrine
in this regard.
And it also has
a lot to do with
locomotion. So one
of the categories of
compounds in the
Parkinson's disease is
to use acetylcholine
antagonist to
help balance out the
lack of dopamine.
All right, last
but not least,
histamine.
The histamine system
is also very important.
We all had the
experience of taking some
allergy drug like Benadryl,
right? So Benadryl
is the first-generation
antihistamine,
and it produces a very
strong drowsy side
effect. So histamine
itself is related
to the arousal. If you
antagonize histamine's
effect, you're going
to promote sleep.
And the histamine
is released by the
posterior lateral
hypothalamus and
the tuberomammillary
nucleus, so
basically in the
hypothalamus area.
and it also project
all over the cortex.
Here is a summary
slide trying to depict
all these different
neurotransmitters,
where is the major
location for,
you know, different
neurotransmitters
to be released,
produced and released.
So here, take
Rafi as example,
you can see
there's a large
serotonergic neurons
population located
right in the
midline And this is
the most important
serotonin-producing
neurons located in
the raffin nuclei.
And another very
prominent one is
dopaminergic neurons
at substantia *****.
This is the main
degenerated structure
in the Parkinson's
disease patients.
This patient has
a greatly reduced
function of the
nigrostriatal
pathway, the
dopaminergic pathways.
So make sure you
review these.
And then locus
cellulis here, LC,
is the most important
norepinephrine
production loci in
the brain. So
we know besides
autonomic sympathetic
nervous system,
norepinephrine is
produced by the locus
cellulis. So make sure
you remember that.
all right after
talking about the five
different neurotransmitters
now let's look at
the circuitry level
what kind of functions
they're controlling
there are ascending
functions and descending
functions as we mentioned
before so the local
functions like
intrinsic connections
controlling brainstem
reflexes is also going
to be covered briefly.
For the ascending, we're
going to talk about
arousal, attention,
and sleep regulations.
That's going to
happen first.
ARAS, Ascending Reticular
Activating System,
or RAS, Reticular
Activating System, are
the most important
system controlling the
awake and sleep cycle
and also conscious
awareness of the
surroundings to wake up and
keep the cerebral
cortex paying attention.
All of those five
projection neurons
that we mentioned are
sending projections
to help us awake
and maintain alert
to maintain our
cognitive function.
Traumatic brain
injuries are the most
important cause for
losing consciousness and
cognitive functions
among all the reasons
FOSS and a motor
vehicle accident took
the about half of the
cases especially for
elderly FOSS is a
very important reason
for the traumatic brain
injury and causing
deficits of cognition
and consciousness.
There is a chart here
to show two aspects
of level of consciousness.
So one is about
alertness, which is
whether awake or sleep.
And the other is
awareness. So awareness
meaning how much do
you, are you able
to communicate with
the environment.
So those two aspects
of consciousness are
both important. As
you can see here, the
normal consciousness
involves both high
awareness and high
alertness. And then the
opposite stream is
coma. So when you have
coma, you would have
extremely low alertness
and low awareness
to the surroundings.
And in between
these two, you have
a different level
of alertness
and awareness.
And for example,
the persistent
vegetative state has high
alert. So this x
-axis is high, but it
doesn't have a lot
of awareness. So it
can't really communicate
with the surroundings,
with people like
caregiver. So they
have low awareness,
but high alertness.
And then, you know,
we're going to
also talk about this
very interesting
characteristic
locked-in syndrome,
which you also
have high alertness
and high awareness, but
the patient just
couldn't move.
So different states,
just remember these
from, you know, the
X and Y axis. what
are these different
states involved with.
First, let's
talk about coma.
So coma is low on
both aspects. As we
mentioned, low
arousal, low alertness,
and low responsive
means low awareness.
So both markers are
low. So it doesn't
have any movement,
and it doesn't
have any sensory.
And usually how we
gauge how much deficits
this person has
using the Glasgow
Coma Scale, so GCS.
Glasgow Coma Scale
is divided into three
major aspects, eye
-opening, verbal response,
and motor response.
So those are several
different aspects and
being given the score from,
you know, either one
to four or one to six,
depending on how many
of these functions
are maintained. And
the normal score is 15.
And the lowest
score actually
is not zero, but three.
And in between, you
have different numbers.
But this number is
important. So if the
Glasgow Coma Scale is
less than or equal to 8,
that means there's
a most likely
severe head injury. So be
sure to remember
this number.
Next one is persistent
vegetative state.
This is a state that the
patient has maintained
the normal sleep
-wake cycle, so their
eyes can open and close.
However, they don't
really respond to
the environment. If
you're trying to communicate
with the patients,
they would not be
able to respond to it.
So there is a famous
patient, her husband
actually filed a
lawsuit to stop her life
support and then her
parents are you know
violently against that
so they had a very long
lawsuit and was terry's
feeding tube being
unplugged four times
and eventually in
2005 her husband won
the case you guys can
search for this patient
online and it was a
very highly public
case and stimulated the
movement like right
to die like protecting
the life you know all
different kind of human
right groups
activities so does this
persistent vegetative
state patients truly do
not have any awareness
to the environment.
Some of the neuroimaging
actually shows
the opposite.
As you can see
here, these are
the, you know,
patient's MRI,
and then these
are the controls.
The both imaging
that's showing,
you know, for the
persistent vegetative
state patients have a
similar type of brain
activation when they're
imagining playing
tennis or when they're
imagining walking
around the home.
So you can see, you
know, those brain regions
that related to the
healthy control is
also lighting up in
the persistent vegetative
state patients.
So this is very
interesting to show that
they do still
understand the command.
They are able to, you
know, change their
mind when they
have, you know, some
external stimuli being
absorbed. However,
they just could not
express themselves
normally to show
their awareness.
So whether this is
across the board to
other patients, it's
still a question.
This is only one
patient being shown
to have these intact
brain signals.
the next one that's a
slightly less severe
than the persistent
vegetative state is called
minimally conscious
state so as you can
see here there are some
consciousness signs
like they have occasional
responses to the
environmental stimulations
some response to
instructions language,
or recognition of
objects. But they're
still pretty consistently
maintaining low
consciousness
compared to the other,
like locked-in syndrome.
So locked-in syndrome
is a very strange
condition. So in this
condition, the patients
are actually fully
aware and fully
alert. So these patients
has a normal ARAS,
and so they are able
to understand and
respond to the
environments, but they just
can't move. So it feels
like they're locked
into this lying
positions, except for
they can move their
eyes. So the minimal
eye movement kind
of show that they do
understand the languages,
instructions, and
they do know what
you're talking about.
And interestingly,
you know, with this
movie, The Diving
Bell and the Butterfly
actually recorded a
true story that the
locked-in patient here
is able to even write
a book by communicating
with his assistant
who would do it
letter by letter for
him when you know she
was asking you know
what letter next
and the patient just
respond by blinking
yes or no so with this
very time-consuming
laborious practice the
patient are able to
was able to write a
book in this movie
and publish the book.
So that means this
type of patient
with Lockheed-In
Syndrome, they do have
intact consciousness
and they can
communicate effectively
with the outside
world with a preserved
eye movement.
One thing to remember
that these can be
caused by severe
pontine lesions that
sever the motor
tracks. Only the motor
tracks, though, because
the sensory tract
are still intact
for these patients.
So the Lochtein
syndrome is permanent
as well. So you can
see here with the
large pontine lesion
due to the ******.
And ALS can also cause
Lochtein syndrome.
So it's the mostly
upper motor neuron
lesion disease. But
when it's severe enough,
the upper motor
neurons of all
the body functions
are impaired.
That's kind of at the
last stage of
their lives.
Usually, the ALS
patients can suffer
from locked-in
syndrome as well.
How exactly does sleep or
wakefulness being
controlled here?
The definition of
sleep, obviously,
we all sleep,
right? So we know we
have reduced motor
activity and decreased
response to the
outside stimuli.
So here, the color
coding with light
green showing the
wakefulness that's
related with arousal.
And then the purple
showing the
importance of these
structures related
with promoting sleep.
As you recall, at
the beginning of this
lecture, we talked
about if we make a
transsection at the
midbrain level, then the
patient will remain
constantly sleepy.
And then if we make
a lesion at the
pons level, and then
the patients will
remain constantly
awake. So that means
this structure in
the brainstem has
very important
regulator functions to
regulating the awake
and sleep cycle.
Let's look at
different stages of
sleep and
wakefulness with EEG.
So the EEG has
different patterns at
different conscious
states. During the wake
with eyes open, these
are the beta waves.
As you can see
here, it looks
small, up and down waves.
And when the person
is relaxed, this wave
becomes bigger, which
is called alpha waves.
And when you have
a non-REM sleep,
so REM means rapid
eye movement.
So non-REM sleep
is a normal sleep.
So REM sleep is
a special type of
sleep. So you can
see that with the
three stages of
a non-REM sleep,
you know, N1, N2,
and N3, the wave gets
bigger and bigger.
So the delta wave
at N3 stage is very
characteristic.
So this one is a
slow wave sleep.
It's, you know, SWS.
The slow wave sleep
is the deepest
sleep a person could
experience. And, you
know, in between
you have N1, looks
more like the, it's
called zeta wave,
looks more like the
awake stage. And
N2 has the
characteristic K complex,
you know, which are
those large spikes
of the sleep waves.
And also sleep
spindles, like the,
you know, all of
a sudden much more
frequent spikes.
So those are the
characteristics for
the N2. So basically,
you can see the
transition from the
awake to deep sleep.
And then the REM
sleep, the rapid eye
movement sleep, is
the strangest one.
As you can see, the
waveform looks more
like awake. It looks
more like a beta wave.
However, it's not
completely the same.
And so we're going
to look at the
different stages further
in the next slide.
From this chart, we can
see as a person aged,
you can see the
normal sleeping
time become
reduced over time.
From the histogram,
we can look at
the sleep patterns
of a normal adult.
You can see initially
when a person
falling asleep, it
goes through all these
stages all the way
to the very deep
sleep, the slow
wave sleep, and then
comes back up to the
REM sleep and then
go back down again
to the deep sleep.
And occasionally you see
the person will wake up,
you know, gain the
full consciousness.
But overall, this
is rare. And then
you can see over
time, you know, when
it's closer to wake
up time, then the
sleep gets shallower
and shallower.
So eventually,
you know, it
becomes awake.
For an older person,
you can see this
pattern become a
lot less rhythmic.
You can see a lot
more wake up time. So
a lot of, you know,
spikes to wake up
time. and also the
initial sleep is shallower
compared to the
normal adult and
then a lot more of this
cycle is going back
and forth between
sleep and wake so the
quality of the sleep
is different now
let's compare the
physiological correlates
during sleep so the
heart rate for the slow
wave sleep, the heart
rate is reduced from
awake. However, for
the REM sleep, it's
actually increased from
the slow wave sleep.
So basically, this REM
sleep is a more active
stage, which correlates
to the EEG when
you have closer to
awake state sleep waves.
The blood pressure
for the slow wave
sleep, you have
decreased blood pressure,
but then this is
increased when you
reach the REM sleep.
And respiration is
also increased from
the slow-wave sleep.
Similarly, the blood
flow to the brain
increases, and the GI
activity is actually
increased during the
slow-wave sleep, so we
actually digest better
when we're sleeping.
and this does not
change in the REM sleep.
Body temperature,
this is an interesting
one. So you have
a reduced body
temperature during
the slow wave
sleep, but then
this is actually
further reduced
during the REM sleep.
Another special part
is that the muscle tone
is also further reduced
from the slow wave
sleep. So this is
actually kind of
correlating to when we
have dreams, right? So the
REM sleep is related
a lot with the dreams.
And then, you know,
we all probably have
the experience that
you're trying to escape
from something
dangerous, but you just
can't move your arms
or legs. It's just
extremely difficult to
move. So that's kind of
correlating to this
reduced muscle tone. So
you're almost acting
like you're awake. But
on the other hand, And
the body temperature
and the muscle tones
are reduced further
from even the slow
-wave sleep. So this is
a very special sleep
stage, the REM sleep.
And then, of course,
the characteristic
rapid eye movement
during this sleep stage.
Now let's talk about the
neurochemistry of sleep.
What kind of
neurotransmitters are
regulating sleep
and wakefulness?
As we know, the
glutamate is a
universal excitatory
neurotransmitters
that promotes
awakefulness.
And so does serotonin,
norepinephrine,
acetylcholine, and
histamine. So those are
all part of the ARAS
system. And so you
need to remember where
they are coming from.
And an additional one
is called hypocretin.
This is a peptide.
Another name for it is
orexin. So it's the same
thing. So hypocritin
actually is produced by
lateral hypothalamus,
and it's found in the
narcolepsy patients.
Basically, these patients
have very low level
of hypocritin in the
brain, and they have
excessive daytime
sleepiness, showing here
for this little girl. So
basically what hypocritin
do is that it
promotes all kinds of
excitatory neurotransmitters
that's releasing,
that promoting
wakefulness, except
for GABA. So GABA
here actually
promotes the negative
feedback control.
But basically, the
hypocritin promotes
all of these excitatory
neurotransmitters to
promote wakefulness.
That's why, you
know, for narcolepsy
patients, if we
need to treat it,
we need to promote
the production of
these excitatory
neurotransmitters.
And the The
neurotransmitters
that are promoting
sleep, we
know a most famous
one is GABA.
So the ones that are
currently used as
sleeping aids, such
as benzodiazepines,
barbiturates, all work
on promoting GABA.
So GABA mainly produced
at the basal forebrain
and hypothalamus.
Those are the most
important areas that
are regulating sleep.
There's also
another very famous
neurotransmitter
called melatonin.
It's a hormone
that's very important
regulating the
circadian cycle.
It's stimulated by
the suprachiasmatic
nucleus and producing,
stimulating pineal
gland to secrete
melatonin. So showing here
the VLPO and the
suprachiasmatic nucleus.
So those are
the important
neurotransmitters that
are promoting sleep.
This is a summary slide.
So you can test
yourself by filling
in what type of
neurotransmitters
and then involved
with wakefulness,
non-REM sleep,
and REM sleep.
So we can fill in
this one by one.
So preoptic area is
secreting GABA, and
GABA is not secreted
very much. It's
inhibited during
wakefulness, but it's
promoted increased
release during the
non-REM sleep, as
well as REM sleep.
Lateral hypothalamus
is producing
orexin and hypocritin.
It's promoting
wakefulness, and
it's inhibited during
the non-REM sleep
and REM sleep.
For the tubular
mammillary nucleus,
we have histamine
produced,
and it's also
promoting wakefulness
and being
inhibited during
the non-REM sleep
and REM sleep.
Raffin nuclei, those
are serotonin-producing
neurons, promoting
wakefulness, and it has
a little bit but
reduced secretion during
the non-REM sleep and
pretty much no secretion
completely inhibited
in the REM sleep.
Locust cerulis is
secreting norepinephrine,
which also promotes
wakefulness and has
a reduced level during
the non-REM sleep
and much inhibited
during the REM sleep.
Basal forebrain is
producing acetylcholine.
Acetylcholine
also producing,
promoting wakefulness,
is also being
reduced during
the non-REM sleep.
However, it's actually
increased release
during the REM
sleep. So you can see
here GABA and acetylcholine.
I use a different
color for them
because GABA is a
major inhibitor in
neurotransmitters here
that promoting sleep.
So it has increased
secretion during
sleep and specifically
it has increased
secretion during REM
sleep as well as
acetylcholine. So just
need to remember this
special situation.
Now, we've mentioned that
for narcolepsy treatment,
we would like to promote
these neurotransmitters
that are promoting
weightfulness.
You can see we use
the uptake inhibitors
for dopamine
norepinephrine serotonin
or dopamine and
norepinephrine together
so these are the
drugs that can
promote sleep
promote awakefulness
and what can we
do to help promote
sleep and you can
see all of these
GABA-related, GABA
potentiators that are
used as a sleeping aid,
and also the serotonin
1A receptor partial
agonist, as well
as orexin receptor
antagonist, and the
melatonin agonist. So
basically, what we want
to do is to increase
the neurotransmitters
that are inhibitory,
right that promotes
sleep increase GABA
increase melatonin
and decrease orexin
or hypocretin
and also a special
serotonin receptor
partial agonist so
these are the mechanism
that makes sense,
right? So once you
learn the sleep
physiology, you will be
able to understand
why we use these type
of compounds to
treat insomnia or to
treat excessive
sleepiness, narcolepsy.
Okay, the descending
projecting
functions from the
reticular formation.
So we have talked
about maturation
and cardiac
reflexes in the
autonomic nervous
system lecture.
And now let's go
through the motor
functions and the
pain regulation
for this descending
modulation.
This is a video
that you can watch
for two very special
rigidity status,
and one called
decorticate, the
other is
decerebrate. So you
can watch this
video at YouTube.
And the descending
motor control from the
brainstem mainly include
the extrapyramidal
tracts. The
extrapyramidal tracts
can start with the
midbrain red nucleus,
reticular formation,
olive and vestibular
nuclei to the
spinal cord. You can
see all of these are
something to the spinal
spinal cord tract.
This extrapyramidal
tract help control
different types of
extensors and flexors.
And when there is
any damage above
the red nucleus,
the patient can
experience
decorticate rigidity.
So decorticate is
actually for the upper
limb the flexor is
activated and for lower limb
the extensor is
actually activated. So
this is because when
there is any damage above
the retinocleus the
rubrospinal tract now
is intact and being in
control, so producing
this very specific
decorticate rigidity.
The cerebrate rigidity
is when the damage
is at or below the
red nucleus level.
And when this happens,
the red nucleus,
the rubrospinal
tract is damaged. And
now the vestibular
and reticular spinal
tracts are dominating.
And now you
would see all four
limbs are extended.
So you can kind
of remember this
by, you know, I
highlighted the core
decorticate, and then
you can imagine the
two fists are coming
into the center or to
the core. So that can
help you remember this
decorticate rigidity.
This is when the red
nucleus, above the red
nucleus is damaged.
Let's talk about the
descending pain
modulation.
So the most important
structure for
the descending
pain modulation is
called periaqueductal
gray, or PAG. So
PAG is very important
to engage the
descending pain
modulatory pathways,
such as locus cerulis
and rastroventromedia
medulla. We call
it RVM. So locus
cerulis is a major
norepinephrine
-producing region. And
we already talked about
it's regulating
the pain sensation.
And rostroventromelial
medulla is connected
with the raphe magnus
that is producing
the serotonin. And
serotonin can also be
projected to the dorsal
horn of the spinal
cord. So all of these
PAG, locus cellulis,
and RVM can produce
projection neurons to
the dorsal horn of
the spinal cord, and
especially the superficial
layer of the spinal
cord, we call it
substantia gelatinosa.
Over there, there are
a lot of encephaline
-containing interneurons
to suppress
pain. So the PAG can
produce very strong,
powerful, descending
pain inhibition.
And in fact, if
you do electrical
stimulation of the PAG
area, you're able to
completely suppress
the pain sensation.
And even patients can
be done, even surgeries
can be done to
those patients that
receive the electrical
stimulation at PAG.
So just alone, without
any anesthetics,
the PAG producing
profound descending
pain inhibition.
And this pathway
actually has been
shown to be altered in
the chronic neuropathic
pain patient.
So this patient has
increased functional
connectivity among
all these structures.
And most likely,
they are actually
promoting descending
facilitation rather
than descending
pain inhibition.
the descending pain
inhibitor system
actually have a very
important clinical
indication related to
the therapeutic you
know the chronic
analgesic efficacy as
you can see here this
study done by Dr.
David Yarninski, he
has discovered that
the CPM, the condition
pain modulation,
expressed by the
patients actually can
predict the efficacy of
a drug deloxetine. So
deloxetine is a SNRI,
so it can increase
the synaptic norepinephrine
and serotonin
concentration. So to
promote or potentiate
this descending
pain inhibitor
system. So the
patients who has less
efficient condition
pain modulation or CPM
actually can benefit
more from this drug.
So this is very useful
when you know clinically
when the doctors
prescribe different
analgesics for patients
to treat chronic pain.
All right. That's all
for today's lecture.
So this is a few
review slides that
you could really
pause the slide, pause
the video, and try to
answer these questions
on your own. So,
for example, these
are five different
circuitry. And are you
able to tell which
neurotransmitters is
involved with these
pathways and which
pathway exactly it
is? So you can fill in
these blanks, and
here are the answers.
Now, the second
summary slide, you can
fill in the blank to
see what anatomical
area producing what kind
of neurotransmitters
in order to produce
arousal, sleep,
motor control,
pain modulation,
bladder control,
and respiration.
So pause the
video now and
fill in the blank
on your own.
Here are the answers.
Same thing here. Try
to test yourself by
fill in the blank for
all of these questions
that I listed here.
These are all the
neurochemicals and
the, you know, related
rigidity that's
really very relevant
to the reticular
formation function.
And again, here
are the answers.
So have you got
these all correctly?
I hope you did.
and if you have
any questions
make sure you
email me and